[Music]
Jeff Snyder here at the Kia telluride
supper suite in Park City and I'm
sitting down with the team behind save
yourselves which sounds really exciting
so let's start the genesis of this
project had her to come together tell a
milliner it was Eleanor's idea she has
to explain yeah I don't know it's just
sort of a thing that we all have I think
a bit of a fear of turning off our
phones and something bad happening and
so we just kind of were like what's the
worst thing and we thought aliens yeah
that was just like it was really just
like a very basic premise and then Alex
and I started writing it together were
kind of brainstorming ideas and the more
we got into it the more it sort of
became a deeper themed movie but also a
very very funny comedy and I heard you
guys work together before no we're a
real-life couple we have worked together
in different capacities like producer
editor shooter or whatever but this was
my agent wrote a movie together and
directed a movie together so that's
pretty cool it was great
but beneath that I have worked together
a lot Oh tell me about the history it
was 2004 and Alex and I were in the same
class at Emerson College we were like
butts right when we were in the Emerson
mafia nice yeah I'm a Boston boy on the
market fattest dad's over if anyone else
is from Emerson now where'd you go to
college I went to a few different
colleges and I dropped out but I'm not
at liberty but you still made it you
made it descendent that's the important
thing
even your disadvantage so we got to
drive yeah yeah I see of South Australia
anyone
degree anymore Jonathan Sunita what
attracted you to this script and it made
you want to play these characters who
unplug didn't have to reconnect the
script my buds John yeah likewise
everybody seemed cool I knew Sunitha
before from the comics in New York and
we were friends and as a big fan and the
script was really funny and it seemed
like it would be chill to make a cool
opportunity it really is like I can't
believe that my my friends wrote this
and we got to make it happen together I
know all that's really vague but I just
can't believe it happened and it was
like a a very interesting thing you know
like when you meet you know you're like
your parents office party or something
for some reason you're there and you
hear like other people talk about your
parents and that's like how it felt like
we everyone was just rising to different
occasions in like it was really lovely
to see friends through different angles
and like just be so in awe again and
they've had low expectations of us and
it was okay yeah so Alex Eleanor have
you ever like been in this sort of
situation not with an alien invasion of
course but have you you know felt the
need to reconnect and unplug and get
away for the weekend nope sure it's a
nice idea we don't actually find that
that would be very valuable we think
that it's probably better to just like
do something for the planet or you know
political cause or something rather than
just like disconnect yourself yeah I
guess that sort of we do love our
characters right but I mean that's sort
of like one of the points that the movie
is like these guys are upstate trying to
like you know discover themselves and do
all these things and it's like meanwhile
the world is actually ending around them
and you know we're kind of a little bit
self-obsessed to see it yeah
if the way I mean if the world was
actually ending would you want to know
would you want to just be blissfully
ignorant about it
mm-hmm yeah well how fast is gonna end
yeah vastly what's we ignorant you have
to use a microphone this is insane we're
editing my [ __ ] out yes sorry yes please
try to use the mic so when you can so we
can always pick up this comedy gold it's
weird that I that's like I don't want to
be helped there's something it's like
don't save me to save yourself Sunita
what are these aliens after in this
movie do we know why there is an alien
invasion obviously a fortune yeah I mean
that's actually one of the things that
we sort of avoided actually and really
in this movie that says era like some
tangible things that they are after that
happened in the script but we were
trying to kind of not go down that that
road of sci-fi where it's like the hero
discovers the thing and saves the day it
was just kind of trying to flip that
every time you think that they're about
to figure it out it's actually just you
finish we were talking about this before
like movies that I love apocalypse type
movies from the from like the 90s that I
love like Independence Day or Armageddon
or something like they sort of figure
out what's going to cause the world to
end they learn about it and then they
solve it and that was a great 90s
feeling like everything was optimistic
if you lived in the States and now like
we're a little more aware there's like
like offshore oil drillers aren't gonna
save us from like a meteor hitting the
planet and like a guy from the CIA isn't
gonna like like outsmart the aliens and
me even though Geoff Colvin was great so
we have like I feel like we're just
trying to make a more realistic movie
Jeff Goldblum actually didn't he said no
to the part but I do love Independence
Day Armageddon classics I mean
Armageddon is a criterion do it is it
because of the song
yeah I think so that that's it the rock
isn't it - honestly what the rock is
criteria thank you for being honest with
yes Sean Connery we're in way off topic
is what would you guys do in the event
of an actual like alien invasion
probably something pretty similar to
what these guys do I don't know so it's
just so uh pending how do you how do you
know I there's like been a few live in
New York and there have been like a few
sometimes conversations with my husband
of like oh we wouldn't get on the subway
like we wouldn't go underground would we
meet back will we try to just like get
back to the apartment we live by the BQE
I don't it's so hard to know I would
probably run and I hopefully I would
like get struck by lightning it depends
on like what's happening the situation
you know you as a couple schools of
thought you can find a Walmart and lock
it down you get a squad of people you
know how to do different things you find
water you go squat in a cabin by the
water because you're gonna want the
water yeah if you were if you are
binging succession you'd probably want
to finish - oh yeah yeah we just we
didn't finish the season though yeah
secession slam oh you guys got
unfinished business with succession we
had this one line in the script that I
we cut from the movie but it was my
favorite it was someone texting them
saying like do still have that air
mattress I think we can use it as a raft
what are you doing you don't have any
survival tools external or internal yeah
you guys have a comedy secret weapon in
this movie and that is John early a big
fan how does he fit into this story and
how'd you lock him down for this I wish
it was actually how we locked him down
yeah
the movie John introduced John
introduced us to John alright John's our
friend yeah he's a funny pal but he is
so funny yeah and he's done search party
with the John and John are on search
party together yeah and John owes me a
lot of favors yeah the last favor
well it's if that sounds terrible the
last video that you shot for John Ellie
were like only if you will be in the
movie I think we text him that oh yeah
you did I'd never would do that you did
I didn't do that was a joke I think that
was that was like before the movie was a
real thing anyway it was just like kind
of like a yeah be in the movie but the
timing was right he was in New York at
the time and he had a window of like an
hour and a half from like 7:30 - I see
what hate him he will like hate us
talking about him okay let's move I
don't wanna upset John early
John you're in another movie here at
Sundance right what are you just like
working with people on glow haha yeah
exclusively fun fact I addition for part
on glow and didn't get it soon as I felt
like it wasn't right for you yeah go to
the peanut butter Falcons wrestling
school I guess John is just the best
that's why he's into movies here and the
cast of glow is so good and that's why
they're everywhere s'mores yeah I was
gonna say Smee are you planning to see
your glow co-stars movies here at the
fest there's so many of them you already
run into a graduate I have I schedules
have not timed out I missed Gayle's
which was this morning and then Ally and
John says tomorrow night and I won't be
here promising young woman's tonight
though Chris and Ally and that's bright
yeah yes that's true there's a peanut
get slipping there it was good it was
good
oh well we're going to try to seahorse
girl - yeah we're here all week though
so we can we can see that later yeah
guys this is a team behind save
yourselves make sure this is a plural or
singular
I'm sure to check it out at Sundance
this week thank you to the Kia Telluride
supper suite for hosting us thanks for
coming guys
yes hahaha mine was lost in the men